[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLIFF REDEKER:
Madames et monsieurs,
we are very excited to
present for you Cirque du
Soleil, "Luzia."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLIFF REDEKER:
Thank you very much.
That was an amazing show.
It's an honor to have
you back at Google.
I'd like to introduce
our panel for today.
So we have Heather Riley, the
company manager for "Luzia."
HEATHER RILEY: Hello.
Thank you.
It's good to be here today.
CLIFF REDEKER: And we
also have Laura Biondo,
the freestyle football artist.
LAURA BIONDO: Hi.
Thank you.
CLIFF REDEKER: We have Rudy
Janecek, the amazing juggler
that you just saw.
RUDY JANECEK: Hello, everybody.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
we have Majo Cornejo.
MAJO CORNEJO: Majo.
CLIFF REDEKER: Majo.
Almost.
MAJO CORNEJO: Hi.
CLIFF REDEKER: And then
finally, we have Abou Traore.
ABOU TRAORE: Hi, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
CLIFF REDEKER: So at Google,
we consider ourselves
a bit of a family.
And I thought I'd start
by asking each of you
how you wound up running
away with the Cirque
and joining the Cirque family.
HEATHER RILEY: Well, I've
been with the Cirque family
now about 15 years,
just over 15 years.
And my original career, I was
an elementary school teacher.
So not much of a difference
between classroom and working
with artists.
But-- no.
With all due respect.
No.
It was actually a
company I worked
for before, a nonprofit company
called Up with People, which
was a different format,
but also in the performing
arts and leadership.
And it was a
colleague from there
who called me at the end
of 2001 and said, Heather,
I think you should join Cirque.
And I've been here ever since.
I've been with five
different shows,
and spent a few years
at our headquarters,
and now working with "Luzia."
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome.
Laura?
LAURA BIONDO:
Well, I started off
playing soccer here in the US.
I used to live in Miami.
Then I moved to Italy where
I played professional.
And as I was there
recovering from an injury,
my brother started to
get into freestyle.
And I started to
see videos with him.
And I would try to do
things like he would do,
because I was really bad.
But then I just kept going
out to a parking lot nearby,
kept training and training.
I got into competitions, live
performances, TV hosting,
TV shows.
And then through a
competition, Cirque
approached me to be part
of this amazing show.
RUDY JANECEK: Hello.
I come from Czech Republic.
I work for "Luzia" show.
And I since six
generation circus.
And I do all life my circus.
And now I perform
in Cirque du Soleil.
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome.
True family.
MAJO CORNEJO: Hi.
I'm Majo Cornejo.
I'm the singer.
I'm from Mexico.
And I'm so proud
to work in "Luzia."
It's a show of my country.
And I'm so happy to be
here with all of us--
all of you.
CLIFF REDEKER: Abou.
ABOU TRAORE: Hello.
I'm from Guinea.
And I play the football
when I was young.
Now it is like 20 years I
playing football soccer.
And in my family we
love the football.
My mother, she's the first.
She's my first fan.
And that's true.
And my brother taught
me the football.
That's why I start the
football freestyle now.
And I love to play football.
And now I'm in Cirque du Soleil.
And I'm so happy.
[APPLAUSE]
CLIFF REDEKER: And this is, in
fact, Cirque's newest touring
production.
So I was wondering
if you could walk me
through some of the stats.
We have some Guinness record
holders, even on this stage.
HEATHER RILEY: We have two
Guinness record holders,
actually, right beside me.
Laura set a record
not so long ago.
You're going to have
to describe that.
And Rudy, when we
were in Toronto.
So what was your--
LAURA BIONDO: Well, I
just did in San Francisco.
It was my fifth
Guinness World Record.
And it was the most amount
of clippers in one minute.
So all of the records
that I hold all
are one trick, the most
amount of that trick performed
in one minute.
HEATHER RILEY: And Rudy,
when we were in Toronto.
Rudy was speed juggling.
RUDY JANECEK: Yes.
I make a record in Toronto.
I juggling five clubs,
three turn, for 30 seconds,
428 turns.
HEATHER RILEY: And it took--
I felt very sorry for the judge
for Rudy's, because it took him
45 minutes in slow motion video
to count all the rotations.
We were on pins and-- he
went across the street
to the hotel to count
and count and count
and validate and such.
But yeah, Rudy smashed
the previous record.
So it was a lot of fun.
We opened last April.
We're just about a year old.
This show has done
about 360 performances.
We started in Montreal, Toronto,
San Francisco, and then here.
And this is the
beginning of a 10
to 12-year journey for "Luzia."
So we have a long,
long way to go still.
CLIFF REDEKER: Great, great.
And also, Abou, as well,
you and your brother
are stars on YouTube.
So thanks for
using our platform.
[LAUGHTER]
So as we saw during the trailer
before everyone got on stage,
"Luzia" is really a triumph
of technology, as well.
There's this massive
conveyor belt.
There's this 3-D
printer for water almost
that comes down from the stage.
How do you source that stuff?
Is there a procurement office?
HEATHER RILEY: We
couldn't bring the water
as one of our main
features in this show.
Obviously, we couldn't
bring it here today.
But we do have the--
the technology is
actually off-the-shelf.
For the rain curtain, there are
spigots that open and close.
And as they open and close
and just gravity takes effect,
that's what makes the
different patterns in the water
that you see.
It's used several times
throughout the show.
And then we also have
a pool in our stage
that's about 8 feet wide and 18
inches deep that we also use.
So 2,000 gallons of water.
First time we've traveled
with water in a show.
So it is an
off-the-shelf product,
but we use it in
a different way.
The conveyor belts that you
see in the opening scene
and then the opening number are
actually from the coal mining
industry in the UK.
Their original purpose is to
take coal out of the mines
and into their crushing
factories and such.
So yeah, we've repurposed
them and turned them into--
they've branded them
as tumble-ators.
CLIFF REDEKER: Tumble-ators.
All right.
Well, we'll have to
do a market analysis
and see how many we
can bring to market.
And it's really
interesting, too,
with just how these are found.
I mean, there's obviously
Cirque du Soleil
infiltrating the coal
industry, or something,
to come up with that.
HEATHER RILEY: I'm not quite
sure where the coal mining
link came from.
It takes about two years
to create a new show.
So when the concepts are
first developed and are first
put out on the
storyboards, from there
it's how do we find what
it is to make that real
and bring those
dreams to reality.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
how do you vacuum up
all the water between acts?
HEATHER RILEY: It's actually--
there's a little machine.
There's two ways.
One, there's a giant
funnel underneath.
There's 100,000
holes in the stage.
So the water first of all
goes through the stage
into a giant pan funnel
and then back out
to our filtration
system in a truck.
But we also have these little--
they look like giant
lawnmowers that
are rolled around on the stage.
It was the invention of
one of our technicians.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, cool.
HEATHER RILEY: The
first version looked
like it was from
the Flintstones,
quite made of wood.
But there's a squeegee on the
front that pushes water in,
and then there's super
absorbent fabric in the middle,
and then there's
fans on the back.
So these get rolled
around on the stage.
Sometimes you see them.
Sometimes you don't.
But that's our last ditch.
And then we also have towels
that the artists bring out
and wipe down the last spots.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
Does technology
inspire the acts?
Or are the acts inspired by the
technology catalog available?
HEATHER RILEY: I think
it's a little of both,
because some of our acts,
our most beautiful things
here take no technology at all.
And others are sort
of tied to that.
So I think it's a
little bit of both.
CLIFF REDEKER: And there's
also an historic pattern, too.
This isn't the first Cirque
show to use Russian swings
or aerial acts or silks.
How do you decide which ones
to go to, how to keep it fresh,
and how to make it
work with the story?
HEATHER RILEY: That's one
of the biggest challenges
is taking acts that
are traditional circus
or traditionally Cirque
and modifying them.
We changed them.
Our Russian swings are
bigger, higher, heavier
than the other shows.
So we can do different
types of tricks.
And that that's really
the evolution of circus
as it continues to grow
and be modified from there.
And it really is a combination
of the vision of the creators
and what's going to
be the best means
to make that result happen.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, awesome.
And there's eight shows a
week, which is a pretty--
HEATHER RILEY: Or 10.
CLIFF REDEKER: Or 10.
Or sometimes 10.
Or even a show at Google,
to make it up to 11.
As company manager, how do
you keep track of things?
What are you really looking
for when the show is live?
HEATHER RILEY: Well, my role
is very much behind the scenes.
I have an artistic
director and artistic team
that are much more
responsible for the quality.
But it's really about balancing
the schedule for the artists,
making sure that they have
the time to train and warm up,
and making sure
they're taken care of.
We have an artistic
team that consists also
with PMeD therapists,
or sports therapists,
that work daily with them,
and coaches for training.
So its about creating
that balance.
We have Mondays off.
That's our one day off a week.
And it depends if it was a
rainy day like last week,
I bet everybody stayed
home and in bed last week
and enjoyed a rainy day.
Otherwise, we're out exploring,
seeing what's going on.
CLIFF REDEKER: And I guess
really for the artists, too,
feel free to jump in.
What are you looking
to achieve every night?
The routine is
always very similar.
When you go onstage,
is there a checklist
in your mind of things to do?
Or is there like an end goal?
Or how do you approach
every night and every show?
LAURA BIONDO: Well,
every show is unique.
So every show is like
the first show you do.
So every time-- even though you
have your same routine to warm
up and get prepared
for your show--
the main goal as a
human being on a stage--
on a Cirque Du Soleil
stage-- is to share something
with the audience and
transmit something,
if there is happiness, or
passion, or excitement,
whatever it is.
So every time you just try
to give your best on stage
and make it unique
for those people that
are watching the show, which
might be the first time they
see something like what we do.
So that's mainly I think
what all of the artists
like to portray onstage.
CLIFF REDEKER: And there's even
improvisation on the music side
as well, because I think
the total length of the show
varies by five minutes or more.
So what are you paying attention
to when you do your singing?
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
HEATHER RILEY: It's very handy
to have a multilingual cast.
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
MAJO CORNEJO: Yes.
All the musicians,
always we use in ears.
And the bandleader, if something
changed during the show,
he is like, super-focused.
And he always tell
us like, hey, guys.
We will change this
part, or vamos to A to B.
And it's like, OK.
And we have televisions.
And it's super--
HEATHER RILEY: If something
happens in the show,
sometimes we repeat
something, sometimes we don't.
It depends on where it is
in an act or something.
The show can also vary just
on the nature of some things
get more quick or not.
But it's pretty
well choreographed.
There's not too much variation.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, cool.
Awesome.
And how do you deal with fatigue
and exercise and warm-ups?
Like, is the time onstage
the exercise and warm-up?
Or is there time during the day?
HEATHER RILEY: I
think for some people
the amount of time-- when
we have 10 shows a week,
there's not as much
training as there is when
there's eight shows a week.
So that's part of it.
We make sure that we
balance that schedule.
But then everybody
has their own routine
of what to do on a day
off, or how to relax.
Abou spends a lot of time
behind a video camera.
And Rudy out exploring.
So there's different
things for everybody.
But that's really our
coaching staff also
that works with that.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, cool.
Awesome.
And so I should also say we
have a Google Moderator set up
as well.
So there's go/ask-luzia if
you want to ask a question.
We'll have time for audience
Q&A towards the end, as well.
I wanted you to tell
me a little bit more
about the Cirque hiring process.
Hiring is one of the
most important things
we do at Google.
And I'm sure the same
is true for Cirque.
So how does one get started?
How does the audition
process work?
HEATHER RILEY: I
think it is a little
different from my experience
to an artist's experience.
For me, it's apply for
a job, and away we go.
But for the artists, it's
really a casting process.
And it's different
also for every act.
Some people are
found on YouTube.
Some people are found
through talent searches.
Some people send in
their videos to us.
We could create our own reality
show of Cirque's Got Talent
kind of idea.
Some people think
they're very talented.
Some people, we think
So it really varies.
We also have scouts
that go to the Olympics
and go to national
championships and such.
We partner with circus schools.
We have across the street very
conveniently from the Cirque
headquarters is the Canadian
National Circus school.
So they can just come right
across and join us from there.
And this show
actually has a number
of artists who have
come from the circuses.
Others, like Rudy, have come
from traditional circus.
So there's a number of
pipelines to get in.
Our goal is to find the best of
the best, or the most unique,
or the most different, based
on what it is we need to do.
CLIFF REDEKER: And there's
18 shows right now.
There's two on the horizon.
So is it increasingly hard
to find artists as the--
HEATHER RILEY: Absolutely.
It's changed.
We've become a bit of our
own competitor in that sense,
because we're all searching
for certain things.
That said, the circus
arts are also growing.
It's a lot more common now.
When Cirque started in
1984, you would never
see circus arts at a concert
or in a performance like that.
Whereas now some things have
become quite mainstream.
So that's both good and
bad for us in that sense.
I think one of
the amazing things
too is artists are now taking
the traditional things that we
use, and they're taking
them to that next level,
like I mentioned before.
So that's also helping
us in that sense.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well, even
like freestyle football
is an up and coming discipline.
There's a federation.
HEATHER RILEY: Never
knew it existed
before I met these guys.
So, yeah.
Absolutely.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
And I also understand that
folks that apply to Cirque,
they apply with a specific
act that's their specialty.
So how specific does that go?
You know, is it better
to be a generalist that's
able to do all manner of--
HEATHER RILEY: I
really think it varies.
And again, depending on who
the artists that come in.
For us, we have some very
specific disciplines.
There's only one show at
Cirque that has football dance,
and that's here.
So these guys, they
want to stay at Cirque.
This is where they're
going to stay.
Singing is something that's
much more multi-disciplinary.
So there's a little more
options for a singer.
And we have a lot of juggling
in our different shows.
So it really depends a
lot on what people do.
And we can-- artists
can transfer from show
to show based on their
different disciplines
if that exists somewhere else.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, cool.
And also, there's cross-training
once you're a part of the show,
as well.
So you have-- well, in
"Corteo," for example,
you have artists
becoming singers,
singers becoming artists.
How do you manage that
training and bring people?
HEATHER RILEY: We always start
with the core of the show.
So for instance,
right now in "Luzia,"
we have our framework
that's set for the show.
And as the artists--
now they've done--
it sounds like a lot.
300 performances
sounds like a lot.
It's not in the grand
scheme of things.
But there is a routine
that gets developed.
And it gives them
the opportunity
to try other things backstage.
So whether it's during
the day in trainings
or in the evenings,
people are encouraged
to learn different disciplines.
And if we can incorporate
that in the show
or create a rotation,
then that's good for us.
We do have some acts
where we already
have that rotation built in.
For instance, the second
number of our show
is an adagio number.
There's three men and one woman
doing this very acrobatic style
of dance.
The woman is literally tossed
between these gentlemen.
And we already built
into the plan--
we have two women that do that.
So they rotate
all the time, just
for their own sakes and such.
But others, you may see an
act that has seven people.
We can do it with
as few as five.
Or we can modify acts and
things along those lines,
too, to build in a little bit
of that security if we need to.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
And it's also a lifetime
career, as well.
So as your artistic
endeavors continue and peak,
there is roles behind the
stage that a lot of artists
will go to in Cirque.
HEATHER RILEY: We've had
artists become coaches and stage
managers and go into that
side of the management.
A lot of people will
return afterwards
maybe back to their homes
and go into coaching.
But we also have artists
who go on to school
and do completely
different careers.
So really, the wide
scope of what's possible.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
Awesome.
I'd like to also talk a
little bit about the show
specifically.
It is a waking dream of Mexico.
So I wanted to learn
a little bit more
about the origins
of that theme, how
you developed the story,
what emotions you're trying
to convey through the piece.
HEATHER RILEY: Well, the idea--
Daniele Finzi Pasca is
the creator of the show.
He also created
"Corteo" for us in 2005
and has stayed in touch
with Cirque over the years.
Daniele and his wife
had lived in Mexico.
He's from Switzerland,
originally.
She's Canadian.
They lived in Mexico
for more than 10 years
and were really taken by
the culture and the people
in the different regions.
And that's what we
do in this show.
It's not a stereotypical
Mexican show.
It's really-- and
I think Majo can
attest-- it's about the beauty.
It's about the differences.
It's about the things
you don't think
you're going to see,
especially at a Cirque show.
It's the first time we've
gone so thematic in something.
People often wonder, well,
it's all sung in Spanish.
And will I understand?
Well, for years Cirque was
in gobbledygook and everybody
understood.
I think you got the
passion from Majo when she
was singing for you earlier.
There was no question whether
or not you understood any of it.
The emotions come through.
And that's the same with this.
We take people on
a journey that's--
every act is a different
setting or a different part
of the country.
So whether you're
in a field of 5,000
flowers with hummingbirds, or
whether you're in a cantina,
or whether you're in
the desert, or a cenote,
every scene changes.
And with it that image
changes of the show.
So that's really the dream
idea of taking us through.
CLIFF REDEKER: And there's
even an airplane flying
metaphor at the very beginning.
HEATHER RILEY: And there's an
airplane and a parachute that
goes horribly wrong
at the beginning,
but it all ends up OK.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
It all works out.
The umbrellas are the way to go.
HEATHER RILEY: Umbrella.
Take an umbrella.
If you're ever going to jump
out of a plane, it's very handy.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
then the scuba diving.
It just all comes together.
So as the tour evolves, is
Latin America on the horizon
for "Luzia" and--
HEATHER RILEY: Plug your
ears, because they're not
supposed to-- no.
Yes.
The idea, again, I said the
show will travel 10 to 12 years.
So we have the entire
world ahead of us.
We'll start in the States now
through mid-2018 is confirmed.
And then after that, we're
still working on the tour plan.
So we'll go from there.
But yeah, certainly
down into Mexico,
Latin America, South America,
Europe, Australia, Asia.
We have a long, long,
long road ahead of us.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
And of course, it encourages
people to make the trip down.
HEATHER RILEY: Not in that
order, just so you know.
Everybody-- Heather,
where are we going?
Where are we going?
They would ask me.
Are we going--
not in that order.
Lots of places to go, though.
CLIFF REDEKER: The passports
for Cirque artists are huge.
And the show evolves
as time goes by.
So some of the existing
shows have found their way
into an arena format.
Acts come and go.
How do you approach
that with the story?
HEATHER RILEY: The
show will evolve.
Certainly, the core of the
show will stay the same.
That won't change.
"Luzia" will always be "Luzia."
But as artists come and go,
they bring in their own flavor.
They bring in their own
different tricks and ideas
to things, as well.
So that can modify over time.
And then the lifespan
of a big top show--
we started in 2006 with
the show "Saltimbanco."
It had traveled all over.
And it was going to be retired.
It was going to be put away
and literally put on the shelf.
And our executives were
like, it's too good to stop.
So we stripped away
all the infrastructure.
And we just toured
with the show.
So that launched a
whole new division
for us-- our arenas division.
And now that's become
the natural transition
to go from a big top
version to an arena version.
And that opens another
three four or five years
of touring to a lot of places.
We're too big.
We're a show that
takes 65 trucks
to move from city to city.
And so we're one and a
half 747s when we travel.
So we can't go to a
lot of smaller places.
And the arena version now
goes into smaller performance
venues-- sporting venues,
hockey rinks, that kind of idea.
So it's opened a
lot of opportunity.
CLIFF REDEKER: And you see
Cirque storytelling tradition
inside, also on cruise
ships, and even on TV.
HEATHER RILEY: And there's
a lot of new projects
that are coming our way,
and a lot of growth that's
happening in our company.
It's a pretty
exciting time for us.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, cool.
So if you have any questions as
part of the Googler audience,
please go ahead
and take the mic.
We'll go to those as well.
There's a few more that I
wanted to cover on my side.
This has been a pressing
question of mine.
It's been on my mind for
years of watching Cirque.
HEATHER RILEY: I'm ready.
CLIFF REDEKER: What is
it with the Quebecois?
It seems like the entire
circus culture of the world
is based out of the sort
of genius in Montreal.
Like, how did that--
HEATHER RILEY: Only for
the last 35, 40-plus years.
No.
In fact, yes, it
started in Quebec.
And yes, there's a very strong
circus culture in Montreal
and in Quebec as a whole.
But really the roots
aren't in Canada
by any stretch of
the imagination.
The traditional circus
has been centuries old.
You know, the Chinese have been
doing it long before any of us.
But I think what's happened
is that incubator started.
And when you get
that little core,
then it grows and
grows and grows.
I've worked with artists
who are coincidentally
Quebecois who've left
Cirque and gone and started
their own small companies.
So that just sort of
feeds upon itself.
Success feeds on success.
There's now a
festival that happens
in the city in the summer.
And it is the
English translation
is completely Cirque.
And everywhere, every street
corner, every little park
has some sort of stage
and people juggling.
And we were lucky
enough, we were
in Montreal last year
when that was happening,
and to be at the sort
of big headliner of it.
But it's fun.
It's really fun.
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome.
I think we have a question here.
HEATHER RILEY: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
congratulations and thank you
for coming to Google.
Now, what I want to know is
what's the origin of the name?
Because I'm from Mexico.
Lucia is actually
with C, not with Z.
HEATHER RILEY: Do you
want to explain the name?
MAJO CORNEJO: En espanol?
AUDIENCE: Si, en espanol.
MAJO CORNEJO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: So it's not
based on the name,
because there is a name Lucia.
HEATHER RILEY: It
is a person's name.
So in English form,
it's the combination
of the word for light
and the combination
of the word for rain.
And we mash them
together to give that.
It is also a person's name.
But our show is thematic--
the light and the rain
play off of each other
throughout the entire show.
CLIFF REDEKER: OK, cool.
And as you mentioned before,
a very international cast.
Is French and English
sort of the lingua Franca?
HEATHER RILEY: Our
main language--
our first language
is all English.
And as people come in,
we have everything.
We have 24 different
nationalities.
But of course, that's broad
cultures that come with that.
So English is our daily
operational language.
But on our site, you'll hear
all sorts of things on the go.
A lot of Spanish,
a lot of French.
Nobody for Rudy.
Rudy's got English now.
But their English has
improved so dramatically, too.
Because Rudy was
actually the first artist
I met when I arrived in Montreal
to start the project last year.
And English has come a long way.
Same with Abou-- from French
to very, very little to now
very, very good in that.
So day to day.
CLIFF REDEKER: All right.
We have some
questions over here.
HEATHER RILEY: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So first I just want to say
that was an amazing performance.
Thank you so much.
I'm actually on the Android
Wear Smart Watch team
here at Google.
So I'm wondering
how do wearables
come into your
performances if at all?
And are there any
plans for that?
HEATHER RILEY: That's
a really good question.
If you want to give us some
to try, I'd be happy-- no.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh.
Underneath your
seat as you exit.
HEATHER RILEY: Where
do I find that?
Actually, we do have
different technology
that we've incorporated
in our show.
And one of the most
amazing pieces of that
is a dress that Majo wears.
Not this particular one, but
she has an electronic dress
that's covered in flowers.
And when she comes out on
the stage, they're all--
red.
Her other dress is white.
And it's covered in
flowers that are closed.
And they're all electronically
coordinated, much more
in your field than mine.
But they're programmed to open.
And as she goes through
the song, the dress blooms.
And it's spectacular
how that happens.
And the programming itself
has a certain pattern,
but that can be modified.
We can have it go in lines or
straight or back and forth.
So that's one of the
biggest uses of technology
that we have right
now in our show.
And the first time in a big
top show, not the first time
in other shows.
"Michael Jackson: The
Immortal World" tour
had electronics built into their
costumes, and a lot of LEDs
and such as well.
The hardest part for us
is-- how do you wash it?
So if you can work on that,
and my head of wardrobe
is back here.
She'll be happy to talk to you.
How do you wash it?
That's what I need
you to work on.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well,
Google Daydream
uses performance fabric.
It was a very important
search for us.
HEATHER RILEY: We can chat.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
And I'm glad you mentioned that.
I think the dress is really one
of the most beautiful, subtle
notes in the whole show.
And there's aerial vehicles
in "Paramour," I think,
in New York.
HEATHER RILEY: Any way we
can use that combination
of technology and arts.
We do a lot more with
video than we ever used to.
And again, for us on
tour, it's about being
able to transport it easily and
be able to clean it afterwards.
Another question.
What did you just do?
LAURA BIONDO: He just
changed the microphone.
HEATHER RILEY: You just messed
up the people in the back.
OK.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: Sort of as
an extension of that,
one of the things that's always
impressed me about Cirque
is how every little
detail is explicitly
designed for maximum visual
impact, down to the belt
buckles, the makeup, color
coordinating the mics even,
just now.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh.
AUDIENCE: And I'm curious--
what is the design
process for that?
And also, how much of it is
done to the individual artist
to decide what they
want specific details
of their aesthetic to be?
HEATHER RILEY: The
original concept
is all done as part of
the creation process.
And we have an extensive
team that does that.
Everything from the acrobatic
elements, costume, makeup.
There's individuals who take
care of all of those things.
When we are in the
creation phase,
and everything is done
sort of at a mock-up level,
that's when the artists
are trying things on.
Does this work?
Does this not?
Can I stretch in it?
Can I juggle?
Can I spin?
So all of those--
people had input on that.
And Rudy's buckle, as much
as it looks metal, it's not.
It's flexible.
It's made of a rubbery
kind of material
so that the artists
aren't getting injured.
So there's a lot of that sort
of research and development
that goes into it.
And then the wear and tear, we
learn things as we go along.
And maybe they need
to be modified or not.
Or it's too long.
Or it's too short.
Or Majo's dress was too
heavy in the beginning.
It weighs about 25 pounds.
So that needed to be modified.
It's literally lowered--
she stands underneath,
and it's lowered from
above with her arms
to get into that dress.
So there's a lot of those
details, you're right,
are taken into effect.
And also, what's it going to
look like from the audience?
You know, you're sitting
there in the dark.
We've got to change
the lighting.
How is that going to look?
That all factors into
how we design something.
CLIFF REDEKER: And it's
all very customized, too.
I mean, these are like one-off--
HEATHER RILEY: Oh, they're
one-offs of everything.
CLIFF REDEKER: --pieces.
HEATHER RILEY: The artists,
we measure them literally head
to toe, every dimension
you can imagine.
They're custom done for
them, for the most part.
The fabrics and stuff, even
the dyeing, the patina--
this would have
all started white.
And we do the painting in
Montreal at our headquarters
so that we can control
the quality of it.
So everything is
pretty much in-house.
Shoes-wise-- those
are off the shelf.
Majo, what shoes do you have on?
No.
Majo's shoes are designed
by us, made by us.
Rudy's are ours.
So yeah.
It depends that as well.
Even from that level,
we do it ourselves.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
Question there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I've been to a
bunch of Cirque shows.
They're great.
But I've noticed over the
years that every so often, I
guess, the performances
that you're trying
are so difficult that
every so often, you--
something-- you mess up.
You do something wrong.
And then you usually
sort of redo it.
And I think even
a couple of things
when I saw "Luzia" this time.
So are you always sort of
trying to push and do things
that you can just sort of
barely do most of the time?
How do you get that balance
between having something
that you can do repeatedly,
and having something
that's challenging
enough that you're really
pushing the envelope?
CLIFF REDEKER: And
what's perfection?
HEATHER RILEY: Well, I think
errors are part of perfection
in what we do.
Because if it's too good and too
perfect, A-- it looks simple.
And B-- it doesn't
look like it--
we must be fooling you somehow.
So to drop something
or to miss something,
there's often a bigger
cheer after the fact
when we do it right
the next time.
I'll let you in on a secret--
in some shows they're stunts.
So we do it on purpose for you.
But then you get the wow factor.
It's like, oh, there
is a risk element.
So it really is that
balance of things.
To be perfect all the
time-- that's not our goal.
To entertain, to give people
what they're looking for--
that's what's
important in the shows.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
it's pretty easy
just to put an extra beat,
an extra stanza in the music
so that people can keep--
HEATHER RILEY:
Well, and that's--
as Majo mentioned
before, our band
can go back and do
something again.
Some tricks they will do again.
Some things they won't.
But we have that
flexibility as well
to be able to make
it happen again.
CLIFF REDEKER: All right.
I think we may have
also had some questions
on Google Moderator as well.
I know one that I
read before the show--
Rudy, do you offer lessons?
I can barely do three balls.
HEATHER RILEY: Can you
teach people how to juggle?
CLIFF REDEKER: An instructional
YouTube channel, perhaps.
RUDY JANECEK: I can, little bit.
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome.
We, in fact, have a very,
very gifted team of--
RUDY JANECEK: You want try?
CLIFF REDEKER: Well, maybe.
It's beyond my-- are there--
[AUDIENCE CHEERS] are there
jugglers in the house?
HEATHER RILEY:
Give me your iPad.
There you go.
It's always good to have a
volunteer or be volun--told.
CLIFF REDEKER: So
these are weighted.
RUDY JANECEK: OK.
So when you try to juggling,
you need to hold it
in your hand at right angle.
CLIFF REDEKER: OK.
RUDY JANECEK: That
you can a good spin.
When you put more higher, you
can try behind or in front.
CLIFF REDEKER: OK.
RUDY JANECEK: And
don't move so much.
Only twist your wrist.
CLIFF REDEKER: Twist.
OK.
All right.
I'm gonna start with the one.
This is on my demo reel
for Cirque du Soleil.
They're still
getting back to me.
But-- whoa.
Almost.
It's heavy.
HEATHER RILEY: We've got more.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
then you can do--
yeah.
And then just bring
in some speed.
RUDY JANECEK: Very good.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
And so--
HEATHER RILEY: I'm responsible
for the artist contracts,
so we can talk later.
CLIFF REDEKER: All right.
Well, actually, my suit was
inspired by the musicians.
HEATHER RILEY: There you go.
We have to paint your collars
red, and make them look--
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
And actually, the snake, right?
You get to walk around with
a snake for half the time.
It's pretty cool.
All right.
Another question.
Go ahead.
HEATHER RILEY: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you walk us
through the creative process?
How long does it take?
And do you typically start
with an idea or theme
and then find artists to fit in?
Or does it ever start with
you find a set of artists
that you really
like and then find
a theme to fit around them?
HEATHER RILEY: The actual
creation of the show
starts with the ideas
from the creator.
I mentioned Daniele before.
And he knew that he
wanted to do this.
He's very good at visualizing
what he wants, and truly
just draws out the
storyboard of where
he sees the creation happening.
That's pretty normal for
most of our creative process.
From there, it's how do we
make that act come true?
What's the best
representation of that image?
I'll use an example
from another show
that Daniele did was "Corteo."
And in there he had
visions of his childhood
and two things that stood
out in his childhood.
One was always
bouncing on a bed,
because kids always
bounce on a bed.
And two was his grandmother
had a giant chandelier
over her dining room table.
And he and his brother used
to always joke about swinging
on grandma's-- or
Nona, in that case--
chandelier.
And in that show, we
built queen-sized beds
with trampolines
instead of mattresses.
And we had giant
chandeliers that
were used as spinning
apparatus for aerialists.
So it's kind of a
combination of the two.
When we're looking for the
artists, and they come in,
we work together with them.
There's a process.
About two years
before we open is
when all of this
visionary process happens.
The research and
development technology
starts about a year before,
a year and a half before.
So six, eight months
in that process.
We bring the artists in
sort of the summer prior to.
So there's about
six months that they
work on the acrobatic elements.
And then the real
push comes starting
in January of the
opening year where
the choreography and
the scenic elements
are all brought together.
And that process
is very intense.
It was a lot of long hours.
So that started for us the
beginning of January last year,
and very intense until April.
So a lot of long hours, a
lot of hurry up and wait,
a lot of try this, do this,
move that, so all of that works.
Moving acts around, oh,
we like that better there.
So that process is very
intense for those months.
And even once we
open, we're still
making modifications to things.
The show is much tighter
than it was a year ago.
We've removed some elements.
We've added some elements in.
So that little bit is
ongoing until we really have,
all right, this is what
we're going to stay with.
So the whole process, a
little over two years from
thought to reality.
CLIFF REDEKER: And are
the different shows
siloed from each other?
Like, if you're
designing "Luzia," is
part of the required reading
to go to Vegas to see
what's going on there?
Or is it kept
completely separate?
HEATHER RILEY: Not necessarily.
It depends on who
the creator is.
Some have done more than
one production for us
and have been
involved with Cirque.
Other people, the show
that's being created now,
which is called
"Volta" and opening
in April, that creation team
had never done anything before.
So they did go around and
look at different shows
and different productions.
Not so much from the
inspiration idea,
but what are my limitations?
Some people who come
to us forget the fact
that we have to pack
this all in a truck.
We have giant
props in this show.
Those conveyor belts
and the Russian swings,
they're massive.
And we have a horse that's
one and a half times
the size of a normal
horse that's a puppet.
It takes up almost half a truck.
So they forget those things.
So that's what we need to sort
of remind the creators-- it
has to fit in a box.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well, and
sometimes the technology
from one show makes
its way into others.
You know, like the
fishbowl in "Zumanity."
You can take that on the
road, and the puppetry
you see in multiple
ones as well.
Cool.
There's a question here, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I want thank you very
much for coming here.
Listening to particular to
you singing in my language
was very moving and touching.
So thank you.
MAJO CORNEJO: Gracias.
AUDIENCE: And I--
gracias a usted.
And I have two questions
for the artist.
Number one, do you ever
think that you are not
going to make it?
And how do you
overcome that feeling?
And number two, what
keeps you motivated?
I have the feeling that
it's like, you're always
about to reach perfection.
And at the same time,
in every show, you do.
But still need to keep
getting better and better.
So how do you deal with
the motivation every day?
HEATHER RILEY: Start
with the second one.
How do you keep motivated?
How do you keep going every
day, different shows, what's
your motivation?
MAJO CORNEJO: OK.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
LAURA BIONDO:
Basically, what she says
is that what motivates her
is the people, because--
and she gave the example when
she met someone in Montreal
in the supermarket.
And she was wearing
the "Luzia" sweater.
And they asked her,
you're from "Luzia."
You're the singer, right?
And she goes, yes.
And then the person
basically just thanked her
because he was
having a rough day.
And that day she was--
to make an example,
there's a part of
the song where it
says that even if
the sky is raining,
you don't have to
be sad, kind of.
So it's like you never know
when you can make a person's
day with what you do.
And we perform every
day, as she said,
in front of 2,500
people every day.
And you never know.
If you do something
good or bad, you always
transmit a message to the
people that are watching you.
So the fact that you go on
stage to share something
with somebody, that's what keeps
her motivated as an artist.
And if I can add to it, I mean,
that main thing is the people,
because we are sharing
something to an audience.
We're not doing
this for ourselves.
We're just transmitting through
what we do something to you.
Also, on the other side, yes.
We are acrobats.
We're athletes.
And another part to keep that
motivation is the fact that you
work with people
that are talented
and always want to do more,
always want to improve.
And we live literally
in an environment
that allows us to become
better at what we do.
So that attaches to that
fear of never making it.
It's not much of a fear
that never making it.
It's more like overcoming
that kind of a doubt,
but it's not really a doubt.
It's just like you don't
know what could happen.
Or like, you don't know
what the boundaries are.
So it's more that excitement.
I see it more as an
excitement than as a fear
that I can't make it.
It's not like, oh, wow.
This is hard.
But it's like, I can
do it if I want to.
I have to push myself.
So it kind of goes from
the motivational part
to not having a fear to also
saying, like, oh my God.
I can inspire someone.
Like, I don't know.
Maybe a kid sees Rudy juggling,
and is like, I want to do that.
Or a girl-- for me-- she sees
me does football, like, soccer
tricks.
And like, if you come from
other parts of the world,
soccer is mainly
like a guy thing.
But then you-- maybe just
a girl who does skateboard.
It's like, I'm going to become
a professional skateboarder.
So it all kind of loops in.
HEATHER RILEY: I think with the
artists, too, one of the things
that they can add--
the show that we did a
year ago, although it's
the same "Luzia,"
now that they're
more comfortable
with the basics,
they can push themselves
that much further.
There's the next step
and the next step.
Even though the act
is the same, there's
how can I give that
little bit more,
how can I-- for themselves,
as much as for the audience
itself.
So there's all sorts
of little things
that are happening
there every day.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLIFF REDEKER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: For the
freestyle footballers--
what's your favorite trick?
And what's the hardest trick?
ABOU TRAORE: My favorite tricks?
OK.
I will show you.
[APPLAUSE]
[KISSING SOUND]
This is-- and I love dancing.
That's why I mix
this with the ball.
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA BIONDO: For
me, my favorite trick
is called the
Clipper, which is also
the last record that I broke.
And it's like this.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Answering to the
second question,
which is the hardest trick.
In freestyle, there's not
really exactly a hardest trick.
There's levels of tricks.
There's like you
can divide them.
If it's like one revolution, two
revolutions, three revolutions.
But the hardest part--
it's always different
for everybody.
But definitely the
most challenging thing
is to try to do as
many tricks as possible
without juggling in between,
which is called a combo.
So it's personal.
Some people find it harder to
learn things with their feet.
learn things with their heads.
But definitely, the
most challenging part
is doing as many as
you can together.
ABOU TRAORE: And for
me, the hardest tricks
is a back salto--
back flip-- with the ball.
Because I take like
two years to really--
CLIFF REDEKER: Perfect it.
Yeah.
LAURA BIONDO: Perfect it.
ABOU TRAORE: Perfect it.
Yeah.
To take two years to
really perfect this trick,
because sometimes I drop.
And I have the injury
with this trick.
And I never give up.
I training every day.
Some time after the show I stay
like, one hour to training,
because every time I want
to make the new tricks.
This is my challenge every day,
because when the people come,
they don't know what is
the football freestyle.
And I want to give
something they never see
and the originality.
And sometimes I make the
football dancing and acrobatic.
That's why people say, OK.
I don't like the
football-- and soccer,
for the American people.
Sometime people tell me,
I don't like the soccer,
but you mix the
football and dancing.
This is I never see it before.
And that's why I love your act.
And this is giving me the
energy to make something strong.
HEATHER RILEY: For us,
that scene in the show
is an urban street
scene, because there's
other members of our
cast are behind them,
kind of the other
teams-- guys and girls.
And we also incorporate rain.
So not only are they
doing those tricks,
but then we also make it
rain during their act.
So we add another
level of difficulty,
in case it wasn't
hard enough to start.
CLIFF REDEKER: And even cast
is building their skills
in freestyle football.
Speaking of that as
well, you [FRENCH].
You've both played the
game of football-- soccer.
So now that you've
moved into freestyle,
do you ever move back
into an actual match?
Like, are those tricks
applicable on the pitch?
Do you incorporate that when
you play the game of soccer?
ABOU TRAORE: No.
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
HEATHER RILEY: Not just
English and Spanish, ladies
and gentlemen.
French too.
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
ABOU TRAORE: Is different
than the tricks.
But some tricks, when
you're playing the soccer,
is like sometimes I can
jump the ball with the hand
and not in soccer.
And soccer is not--
you can't make this, because if
you do this, is like the foul.
That's why.
LAURA BIONDO: We normally on our
days off-- there's not only us,
but there's other
artists, like Rudy himself
and part of the musicians,
we all like to play.
So we organize little
games among ourselves.
And we go out to play, because
we're passionate about it.
In fact, during like
World Cups or Europeans,
we have like projecting
things on the walls of Vizio.
But you can use some
tricks in the game.
It depends.
But mainly, freestyle helps
a lot on the ball control
and in your confidence.
So when you go play,
even though you're not
going to do a bunch
of crazy tricks,
you do have a confidence
in trying things.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
then in agility, too.
LAURA BIONDO: Yeah.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, yes.
One final audience question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
you're constantly pushing
the boundaries of the body.
And that comes with injuries.
I was wondering how often
do acrobats get injured?
And how do you deal with that?
HEATHER RILEY: More
often than we'd like
is one answer, but not as often
as people think is the other.
Injuries can range from
anything that's little.
It can be lots of
bumps and bruises.
People always have
That's pretty normal.
If it's something that's
more serious or significant,
we partner with the local
medical community in case
we need that level
of intervention.
As much as we can, we
manage things in house
with our sports therapists
that are with us.
And you know, if necessary,
yes, there's surgeries.
There have been broken
bones and things like that.
But we really try and mitigate
that as much as we can.
If somebody is out of the show--
it could be for
a couple of days.
It could be for a
couple of weeks.
It depends.
And if they're going to be out
for an extended period of time,
we send them home, because
the best place to get better
is usually with mom
taking care of you
and doing those sort of things.
We send people home
for their rehab,
and then they come back when
they're ready to train again.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
on-site massage
therapy, just like Google.
HEATHER RILEY: Oh, yeah.
They have massages.
We saw your haircut
truck out here.
That's what I was jealous about.
But yeah, we have
massage therapists also
that come with us.
And again, we get the
support of the community.
It's one of our
benefits, I guess,
because we're so well known,
we use the same doctors
as the sharks kind of idea.
You know.
CLIFF REDEKER: OK.
The last audience question.
AUDIENCE: With so much that
you create at so many levels,
from the footwear design to
repurposing mining equipment,
I'm really curious if you could
talk about what your design
shop is like at the technical
and physical creation level.
You've got to have a lot
of interesting people
with diverse backgrounds.
HEATHER RILEY: Our studio
is a lot smaller than this,
let me tell you.
There's about 2,500
employees that
work at our headquarters
in Montreal.
Everything from lawyers and
accountants and that side
to our creative team.
Our headquarters is kind
of designed as a factory.
So it also has an
industrial look to it.
And one wing is completely
that creation side--
from the costume shop, one
floor has all the fabric work
and the sewing and the
hats, another floor's
got more of the patterning
and does wigs and shoes.
The opposite side is a
technical creation shop.
So I think there's probably
about 500 to 600 people that
work on that full-time for us,
working on the different shows.
And they work
project to project.
So we have a team that does
the maintenance for our show.
And then there's teams
that do creations as well.
So they rotate back and
forth on different things.
CLIFF REDEKER: And in each
show, as well, there's
a complete mirror of the stage
backstage for practice too.
HEATHER RILEY: Yeah, absolutely.
So what you don't usually
see from the front.
You come in the entrance
tent in the big top itself.
And behind that's what we
call the artistic tent.
And in that tent is
their dressing rooms,
the training area.
So during the show people are
warming up or cooling down,
depending on where they are
in the series of things.
They can watch from monitors
of what's happening,
so they know when to
go on and off stage.
We have our wardrobe team.
I have a head of wardrobe.
And she has two assistants
plus local staff,
plus the physios and such and
coaches are all back there
making that happen.
So it's kind of our
beehive backstage.
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome.
So the last question
that I had-- and you
touched on Majo's dress.
But for anyone on
the stage as well,
what's one detail that
the audience may not
be paying attention
to that they need
to tilt their gaze when
they're watching the show.
Like what's one little
trick or little homage
that you wish people would
pay more attention to?
HEATHER RILEY: You want
to go down the line.
We'll see.
What's something that people
need to watch for in the show?
Something they might miss?
CLIFF REDEKER: I like
the little robot guy
that mows the flowers.
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
ABOU TRAORE: For
me is the smile.
The smile-- because
it's important
when you give the
smile with the people,
and people can
remember everything.
And when they come to
home, they say, OK.
I saw the show.
But the guy, when
he played soccer,
it gave me the
motivation of the smile.
And then I can keep this
for the memory every time.
And that's why I
love playing soccer.
And I share the smile
with the people.
CLIFF REDEKER: Anyone else?
LAURA BIONDO: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
CLIFF REDEKER: Well,
the dress is amazing.
HEATHER RILEY: Your dress
is pretty amazing, though.
MAJO CORNEJO: This
show, it's so beautiful.
HEATHER RILEY: I think one
thing if I can recommend
is, if you can, come
see a show twice.
Because the first
time we're going
to make you look
certain directions.
We're going to force you to
watch something on that stage
while we're doing something
over here to clean up or change.
So we draw the attention one way
to make something else happen.
What I suggest to people if
you can come a second time
is don't watch the main thing.
Watch the other place, because
that's the other little magic,
like those machines that clean.
We do that in the dark.
But we focus on
something in front.
So there's a lot of those
little tricks that happen.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
even the artists
that are spotting each other and
conversing in the background.
HEATHER RILEY: Try-- again,
you need to come twice.
CLIFF REDEKER: Three times.
HEATHER RILEY: Or more.
But if you can, don't
watch the main thing
if you can take your
eyes away from it.
That's my suggestion.
And then you see those
other little moments
that are going on.
And often, a lot of little
interactions and jokes
that these guys have on stage.
They're playing with each other
even more than what you see.
So no, it's fun.
Come see it again.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
Cirque, the San Jose run
is through mid-March.
And then it goes on the road.
We have Chicago.
We have Los Angeles.
HEATHER RILEY:
We're playing down
in San Jose just off of Taylor
Street until March the 19th.
From here we go to Seattle,
then Denver, Chicago, Atlanta,
and LA will wrap up our
year for us this year.
CLIFF REDEKER: Excellent.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
HEATHER RILEY: Merci.
CLIFF REDEKER: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
HEATHER RILEY: Tres bien!
CLIFF REDEKER: And
thank you very much,
Cirque du Soleil people.
HEATHER RILEY:
It's our pleasure.
Thank you.
ABOU TRAORE: Thank
you, everybody.
CLIFF REDEKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]